when I started dating I had to give
people to sign
um ndas and it took me a while to get
wrap my head around it because it's just
very impersonal but someone in our
position needs to do that Raven Simone
revealing how she's kept her personal
life private all these years how big is
your file
I told you all the naughty stuff
some good times I Am A type personality
I'm very strategic
very very strategic I don't talk about
me well she's opening up now about her
past dating life on the Howie Mandel
does stuff podcast including how all her
romances involved a non-disclosure
agreement at what point in the date or
the relationship do you say I have some
paperwork for you before the naughty
times come
serious like right before naughty time
comes so you have you have uh paperwork
on your nightstand
yes
not always on the nightstand it might be
having the day like the day before
whatever but Raven says she's not the
only one in Hollywood who does this you
know it's gotten worse now they have
consent forms who's stopping to read
these documents ahead of time in the
lawyers right there in the room
welcome to being a celebrity in
Hollywood nowadays well it's true though
nowadays hashtags real life they change
the dynamic of having an intimate
relationship with somebody of course
Raven's no stranger to being in the
spotlight
oh my game is football
since early on in her career the former
Child Star has been pretty hush-hush
about her personal life I don't like to
talk about myself and when I do it means
I'm for reals about it because once you
put it out there you can't be like well
I take it back when I'm ready for you to
know them you will know them
fast forward to 2020 and Raven let
people know she married longtime partner
Miranda Pearman Mayday we are not
ignorant to the fact that when something
so big comes out especially for me who
has been private with their lives and
their dating life for so long we were
pleasantly surprised we were grateful
and thankful for all the love that came
our way and still comes our way
so how did Miranda feel about the NDA
part of her relationship with Raven
she's like
for me please
because she knew that we had something
different like it just feels different
we both were like this is this takes
away such
like the genuineness of it all I've been
kind of this open book my whole life but
I also haven't been in the public eye
Raven is also helping me learn where to
set those boundaries and draw those
lines
um just to protect myself our
relationship and it's a good balance
well Raven says Miranda signed the NDA
and the relationship has gone further
than she imagined it would she did it
but she's also proven to me
beyond the three pages it's three pages
you have articles you've got articles
and then the ABC's
[Music]